This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
这是一个 iHeart 播客。绝对真人。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the Outer. My Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
并试着去理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。那真是个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at it。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
嗨，大家近来如何？欢迎收听《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们最喜欢的心理治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯。这个节目探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都感觉不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位经验丰富的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套隐形铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着你有能力这样做，你就必须这样做。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much. I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Lusbian. Michael Mancini.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这段怀孕经历似乎是一场骗局。你两次篡改了这个特定的测试……我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·卢斯比安。迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临后果。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。2%。这是在也有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养韧性的方法。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。那是“TWO percent”。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个惯犯骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Gemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of your 20s. Today, I want to talk about heartbreak. I want to talk about why it is so hard, but it also give you kind of a guide based on psychology and my experience on how. How to get over it. Maybe that's not even the best way to say it. How to get through it. How to process
他会得到应有的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，这是一个探讨我们20多岁时经历的最大变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到这个播客。新听友，老听友，无论你在世界的哪一个角落。很高兴你能来到这里，收听又一期节目，当然，我们要一起剖析20多岁时的心理。今天，我想聊聊心碎。我想聊聊为什么它如此艰难，但同时也会根据心理学和我的经验，为你提供一份指南。怎么走出来。也许这不是最好的表达方式。如何熬过去。如何处理
the loss. How to still feel strong enough to believe in love. How to find love again. I want to begin by telling you all the story of my worst breakup. And when I say breakup, I should actually say breakups as in plural. In 2021, I went through two breakups. in one year. One with a person that I was in a long-term relationship with, a serious relationship with, and another with someone, you know, and the relationship was a lot less serious, but someone who I deeply cared for and I can admit to myself now, like, definitely loved very, very much. Let me describe kind of like the circumstances of the two-in-one year breakup situation, of the very tragic year that happened to me. I had been dating my first very serious boyfriend for about two years
这份失落。如何依然保持足够强大的力量去相信爱。如何再次找到爱。我想先给大家讲讲我最糟糕的分手经历。当我说分手时，其实应该用复数，也就是“分手们”。2021年，我经历了两次分手。在一年之内。一次是和我处于长期恋爱关系、严肃恋爱关系中的人，另一次是和另一个人——你知道的，这段关系没有那么严肃，但我曾深深在乎过他，我现在可以向自己承认，绝对是爱得很深、非常爱。让我描述一下一年内经历两次分手这种情况的背景，描述一下发生在我身上那个非常悲惨的年份。我和我的第一任非常严肃的男友大约交往了两年
when I think I just realized, you know, I think we both realized we just weren't right for each other. I actually remember him. I distinctly remember him trying to break up with me a few months before we actually did because he was like, I'm writing my thesis and I'm just going to be too busy for you and like I need to focus all my attention on my writing and I won't have time to be with you and I don't know why, but I like stayed with him, even though that was like the beginning of the end. And eventually I was the person to break up with him two days before Valentine's Day, I should say, because of course, that was my luck. But it wasn't going to work. And I think it was for the best. And after we broke up, we did this like on and off again thing for a few months before
当我想我只是意识到，你知道的，我想我们俩都意识到我们只是不适合彼此。我实际上记得他。我清楚地记得他在我们真正分手几个月前试图跟我分手，因为他说，我在写论文，我实在太忙了，顾不上你，我需要把所有的注意力都集中在写作上，我没有时间陪你，我不知道为什么，但我还是留在他身边，尽管那是结束的开始。最终，我成了那个在情人节前两天提出分手的人，我必须说，因为这当然是我的运气。但这行不通。我想这是最好的结果。分手后，我们有几个月处于这种分分合合的状态，直到
I realized he actually had a new girlfriend he wasn't telling me about. And it was very embarrassing. and I was in this small college town and everybody knew and I kept telling people like, we're going to try and make it work. Meanwhile, he was completely like he was seeing somebody else. It was terribly painful and it kind of took four months for me to like officially begin to grieve our relationship because of all that happened and because there was this delayed emotional reaction. It took me a while to realize like, oh, this is it.
我意识到他其实有了新女朋友，而他一直瞒着我。这非常尴尬。当时我在这个大学小镇里，人人都知道，我还一直在告诉大家，我们会努力让这段关系继续下去。与此同时，他完全就像——他在和别人约会。这极其痛苦，而且我花了四个月的时间才正式开始为我们的关系感到悲伤，因为发生了这一切，也因为这种延迟的情感反应。我花了很长时间才意识到，哦，就是这样。
We actually aren't getting back together. And that's when the grief. really began. I'm also very grateful for that breakup because OG listeners of the podcast will know that is how the psychology of your 20s started. And I think that it was like the thing that I needed to expand my life and to take a risk and to be creative and to know what I cared about. So I kind of owe him a bit of a thank you. I owe him my dream job. So thank you very much. But that is a different story for another time. I think after that breakup, I'd love to say that I like healed and I moved on and I started dating an appropriate amount of time later,
我们真的不会复合了。就在那时，悲伤。才真正开始。我也非常感谢那次分手，因为播客的老听友都会知道，《The Psychology of Your 20s》就是这样开始的。我想这正是我拓展生活、承担风险、发挥创造力以及明确自己真正在乎什么所需要的东西。所以我觉得我多少应该感谢他。我欠他一份我梦想中的工作。所以非常感谢。但这又是另一个故事了。我想在那次分手之后，我很想说我已经疗愈了、我放下了，并在适当的时间之后开始约会，
but that is not the case. I was really, really lonely and I went back on the dating apps well before I should have and ended up in a six-month situation with someone, you know, I shouldn't have been in a relationship with, but we ended up going on holidays together and we met, I met his parents and I really thought we like had this future, which we never did. And from the beginning, he was very clear. He didn't want a relationship. He was never going to commit to me. And, you know, I think that I just didn't want to hear that and I didn't want to see it. And so I put a lot of hope and energy and love into this person. And then, you know, six months later, that was the end. And I realized again, like, this person doesn't really respect me very much. This person really doesn't want to be with me.
但事实并非如此。我真的、真的很寂寞，在不该回去的时候就早早回到了约会软件上，结果和一个我不该和其建立关系的人陷入了长达六个月的“友达以上”关系中，你知道的，但我们最后一起去度假了，我们见面了，我见了他的父母，我真的以为我们会有这样的未来，而我们从来没有。从一开始，他就说得很清楚。他不想谈恋爱。他永远不会对我做出承诺，而且，你知道的，我想我只是不想听进去，也不想去面对。所以我把许多希望、精力和爱都倾注在这个人身上。然后，你知道的，六个月后，一切就结束了。我又一次意识到，这个人其实并没有那么尊重我。这个人真的不想和我在一起。
I can't force him to and I have my heartbroken again. These moments now are so formative for the person that I am to the point where I'm, I genuinely think they're some of the things that I'm most grateful for in my life. Like those heartbreaks shaped me and they also pushed me to an emotional limit that I think gave me some good wisdom to share on how to survive these situations. in the time since, like I've dated a few people, I went through one other breakup where I got to apply so many of the learnings from those two big breakups. And now I'm in a three-year relationship with somebody that I love so much. I adore him. He is incredible and, you know, almost five years
我不能勉强他，我的心再次碎了。这些时刻如今对我现在的性格塑造起到了至关重要的作用，以至于我真的认为它们是我生活中最感激的事情之一。就像那些心碎塑造了我，它们也将我推向了一个情感极限，我认为这为我分享如何熬过这些情况提供了一些好的智慧。在那之后的这段时间里，就像我和几个人约过会，我经历过另一次分手，在那次分手中，我得以运用从那两次重大分手中学到的很多经验。现在我和一个我非常爱的人维持着三年的恋爱关系。我崇拜他。他太棒了，而且，你知道的，差不多五年
on, I want to look back today and just kind of give you a psychological guide to how I got through it and how hopefully you can as well. I know this moment is so painful. I know that actually nobody experiences this in the same way and that I'm sure you think you're never going to find love again. You're never going to be able to survive without them. You can't imagine a future where like their name isn't in your phone and they don't know everything about you. But I promise you will get there. The feeling of emptiness you have won't be forever. And I want to give you a little bit of a guide through. So without further ado, let's get into the psychology behind how to survive your breakup, how to survive heartbreak. Stay with us. Let's start very, very
过去了，今天我想回顾过去，给你提供一份心理学指南，告诉你我是如何熬过来的，以及希望你也能如何熬过来。我知道这个时刻非常痛苦。我知道其实没有人以同样的方式经历这一切，而且我确信你认为自己再也不会找到真爱了。你觉得没有他们你根本无法活下去。你无法想象这样一个未来：你的手机通讯录里没有他们的名字，而他们却对你的一切了如指掌。但我向你保证，你会熬过去的。你内心的空虚感不会永远持续下去。我想为你提供一份指引。所以废话不多说，让我们进入关于如何度过分手、如何熬过心碎背后的心理学。跟我们在一起。让我们从非常、非常
simply. Why do breakups hurt so much? And it might seem simple. Anybody who has lived through it knows it's deeply complex. There are basically a few reasons why you're in so much pain right now. And there's a reason why they call it heartbreak, because that deep feeling in your chest, in your lungs in your limbs is real literal physical pain. We're going to get to how I know that to be true in a second, but the most simple rudimentary psychological explanation for why I break up hurts so much is this. Love, like few other things, makes us feel amazing to a degree that really has no rivals. It makes us feel incredible, to be seen, to feel important, to connect with somebody else. Obviously, it brings a lot of pleasure to be loved, to be like in this deep bonding moment
简单的事情开始。为什么分手会这么痛？这看起来可能很简单。任何经历过的人都知道这极其复杂。你现在之所以痛苦不堪，基本上有几个原因。这也是为什么人们把它叫做“心碎”，因为你胸腔、肺部和四肢深处的那种感觉是真实存在的、物理上的肉体痛苦。我们稍后会讲到我是如何知道这是真的，但对于分手为什么如此痛苦，最简单、最基础的心理学解释是这样的。爱，就像少数其他事情一样，能让我们感到无比美妙，达到了无可匹敌的程度。它让我们感觉不可思议，被看到，感到重要，与另一个人建立联系。显然，被爱，处于这种与某人的深度绑定时刻，会带来很多快乐。
with somebody. And what's really behind those feelings, what really drives those feelings is dopamine and oxytocin. Oxytocin especially is literally known as the love hormone. And if you ever, if anybody ever managed to purify it and give it to somebody in a vile, it would be one of the most potent and strong drugs out there. It would also be one of the most addictive. That is how intense of a drug and of a feeling it is. Now, oxytocin isn't just about love. It's also what allows us to bond and trust other people. And it is essential for building neural pathways that basically weave the memories and our emotions about somebody into our brain. They live, leave an imprint. The memory of them will leave an imprint on your neural structures. And the flexibility
而这些感受背后真正起作用的、真正驱动这些感受的是多巴胺和催产素。催产素尤其被称为“爱情荷尔蒙”。如果有人能够提纯它并装在小瓶里送给别人，它将是现存最效力、最强烈的药物之一。它也将是最容易上瘾的药物之一。它的药效和带来的感觉就是这么强烈。现在，催产素不仅仅关乎爱。它也是让我们能够与他人建立纽带和信任的物质。对于建立神经通路来说，它至关重要，这些神经通路基本上将关于某人的记忆和情感编织进我们的大脑中。它们留下了印记。关于他们的记忆会给你的神经结构留下印记。而大脑的
of the brain means that in response to all this really deep, emotional, intense stuff, it adapts to expect it. It adapts to deepen that imprint to become reliant on the dopamine and the oxytocin provided by this person to rely on them more and more. And so when it ends and all those positive sensations go away and that imprint is no longer filled, suddenly there is a deep, emotional, psychological, biological, and biological emptiness that our brain just can't comprehend. It can't comprehend that this person was here, they were with us, we loved them,
灵活性意味着，为了应对所有这些非常深刻、充满情感、强烈的事物，它会适应这种期待。它会适应加深这种印记，变得依赖这个人提供的多巴胺和催产素，越来越依赖他们。所以当关系结束，所有这些积极的感觉消失，那个印记不再被填补时，突然之间，就会出现一种深深的情感、心理、生物学层面的空虚，而我们的大脑根本无法理解。它无法理解这个人曾经在这里，他们和我们在一起，我们爱过他们，
and then it was over. the hole was no longer filled. Scientists and psychologists, you will hear them make comparisons between a breakup and literal drug withdrawal. It is like your brain is detoxing from a substance and that substance is this other person. You don't have access to them anymore and your brain still very much wants to,
然后一切都结束了。那个空洞不再被填补。科学家和心理学家，你会听到他们将分手与真正的戒毒作对比。这就像你的大脑在从某种物质中排毒，而这种物质就是另一个人。你再也无法接触到他们，而你的大脑仍然非常渴望，
your brain still very much expects to and so you are undeniably left very hurt. and left very lacking or longing or yearning because of this situation. That pain your feeling is not in your head. It is very much real. Studies including a very famous one from 2012 have shown that relationship breakdown activates the same brain regions that process physical pain. You've probably heard that before,
你的大脑仍然非常期待，所以你无可避免地受到了深深的伤害。并且因为这种情况而留下了深深的缺失、渴望或思念。你感受到的痛苦并不只是你的胡思乱想。它是非常真实的。包括2012年一项非常著名的研究在内的多项研究表明，关系的破裂会激活处理身体痛苦的相同大脑区域。你可能以前听过这个说法，
but the kind of pain they're describing is obviously not the same as stubbing your toe or breaking a limb. It's really known as social pain, the pain of losing a social connection, the pain of rejection, the pain of feeling deep longing and missing for somebody that really connects to a pain in how we saw ourselves that we no longer have. You know, we saw ourselves as this person who was attached to this other individual. We saw ourselves in a partnership. We saw ourselves in a pair. And we no longer do. do. And so there is also a real identity shaker that is going on behind the scenes. Back to that pain thing as well, it's not like there is a hierarchy where physical pain hurts more than this social pain,
但他们所描述的那种痛苦显然不同于踢到脚趾或肢体骨折。它通常被称为社会痛，即失去社交连接的痛苦、被拒绝的痛苦、对一个真正与我们曾经拥有过的自我认同产生关联的某人产生深深思念和怀念的痛苦。你知道的，我们曾把自己看作是依附于另一个个体的人。我们认为自己处于一段伙伴关系中。我们认为自己是一对。而我们不再是了。因此，幕后其实也发生了一场真正的自我认同震撼。回到关于痛苦的那一点，并不是说存在某种等级制度，即身体痛苦比这种社会痛更痛、
hurts more than this social loss. They hurt equally, which might seem bizarre to say, but they hurt equally because pain is not actually experienced by the body. It is experienced by the mind and by the brain. specifically pain related neural regions in your brain. I could cut off your leg. I could, you know, kick you in the shin. You would not feel any of that as actual pain if the pain related neural regions in your brain were not working because you would have no way of reading the sensation.
比这种社会损失更痛。它们的痛感是一样的，这听起来可能很奇怪，但它们的痛感是一样的，因为痛苦其实并不是由身体体验到的。它是被心灵和大脑体验到的。具体来说，是你大脑中与痛苦相关的神经区域。我可以砍掉你的腿。我可以，你知道的，踢你的胫骨。如果你大脑中与痛苦相关的神经区域没有在工作，你根本不会觉得那是真正的痛苦，因为你将无法解读这种感觉。
What that means is that the pain of a heartbreak is processed in the same way and at the same capacity and level as physical, pain would be. They use identical systems. So I don't want you to discount what you're feeling and think, oh, this is not real. This can't be as painful as I think it is. This is all in my head. Absolutely not. There is real science behind why you feel the way that you do. Breakups also leave us with an emotional void where there's a lot of love that has nowhere to go. And they also leave us with a near future void. What I mean by a near future void is that it makes us have to rapidly adapt to a new way of
这意味着心碎的痛苦是以与身体痛苦相同的方式、在相同的容量和水平上被处理的。它们使用的是相同的系统。所以我不想让你否定你的感受，并认为，哦，这不是真的。这不可能像我想象的那么痛苦。这都是我的一厢情愿。绝对不是。你之所以会有这种感受，背后是有真正的科学依据的。分手还会在我们心中留下情感真空，那里有大量的爱无处可去。它们还给我们留下了一个近未来真空。我所说的“近未来真空”是指，它迫使我们快速适应一种新的生活方式，
life whilst also accepting the grief of a future that is never going to happen. You're not going to see each other every weekend. The future trip that you so wanted to take isn't going to happen. They're not going to be at your birthday next year. It's like they've been erased out of all those future memories that you want to have. All the things that you built, the routine, the inside jokes, the connection, the relationships with their family, the memories. It feels like you have to erase them not just from the past and the present but from the future. And you have to say goodbye and that those memories were maybe for nothing. This has a name, it's called ambiguous loss, grieving something that hasn't happened yet,
同时还要接受一个永远不会发生的未来的悲伤。你们不会每个周末都见面了。你们那么想要进行的未来旅行不会发生了。明年你的生日他们不会出席了。就像他们从你想要拥有的所有未来记忆中被抹去了一样。所有你们共同建立的东西、日常生活、内部笑话、联系、与他们家人的关系、那些记忆。感觉你不仅要把他们从过去和现在中抹去，还要从未来中抹去。你必须说再见，并且觉得那些记忆可能都是白费力气。这有个专有名词，叫做“模棱两可的失落”（ambiguous loss），为尚未发生的事情悲伤，
but that you still miss in a way, grieving the future that you really wanted to build with this person, building a life that you were deeply invested in. I personally think some of the hardest breakups are the ones when it could have almost worked. You think it's working. You tried really hard or you were just blindsided and the plans, the potential, they were just like suddenly killed off in the moment. You know, it's a random Monday night and
但你在某种程度上依然会想念它，为真正想要与这个人共同建立的未来而悲伤，建立一个你倾注了深厚感情的生活。我个人认为，最艰难的分手之一是那些本来差一点就能成功的关系。你以为它正在奏效。你付出了巨大的努力，或者你只是被打了个措手不及，而那些计划、潜能在那一刻突然被掐断了。你知道的，那是一个平常的周一晚上，
your whole life is suddenly different. Half the pain is just having to adapt to this new reality that you probably didn't want to find yourself in in the first place. I think it's the same for relationships that maybe didn't have a serious label. Just because you weren't boyfriend and girlfriend, just because you weren't formally together, even if it was a situation ship, there is a part of you that always deeply hopes that it could work out.
你的整个生活突然变得面目全非。痛苦的一半原因在于，你不得不去适应这个你可能一开始根本不想身处的新现实。我认为那些可能没有严肃名分的恋爱关系也是如此。仅仅因为你们不是男友和女朋友，仅仅因为你们没有正式在一起，即使只是一段“暧昧关系”，你的内心深处也总有一部分深深地希望它能成功。
And there is a part of you that really holds on to the what if. And a lot of psychologists will tell you that it's the what-ifs that make the pain last as long as it does. And why it's so hard to find closure? Because the opposite of closure is possibility. And that's what the what-ifs are thriving in. What if they've just given me a chance? What if things had been different? What if we hadn't had that fight?
你的内心深处有一部分紧紧抓着“如果”不放。很多心理学家会告诉你，正是这些“如果”让痛苦持续了这么久，也是为什么很难找到释怀（closure）。因为释怀的反面是可能性。而这正是“如果”繁衍生息的土壤。如果他们当时肯给我一次机会呢？如果事情有所不同呢？如果我们没有吵那一架呢？
What if I hadn't broken up with them over that thing? What if I just loved them a little bit more? what if they just loved me a little bit more. There was this Psychology Today article that I read about this that said, the reason these what ifs haunt us is because they actually offer us a false sense of control. If we can pinpoint what went wrong, we can maybe fix it and get back together with them or we can prevent it from happening again. We search for things that will fill in the gaps of why this didn't work.
如果我没有因为那件事跟他们分手呢？如果我当时再多爱他们一点呢？如果他们当时能多爱我一点呢。《今日心理学》（Psychology Today）上有一篇关于这个的文章说，这些“如果”之所以萦绕在我们心头，是因为它们实际上为我们提供了一种虚假的掌控感。如果我们能指出哪里出了问题，我们或许就能修复它，并与他们复合，或者我们可以防止它再次发生。我们在寻找能够填补这段关系为什么会失败的空白的原因。
The hard truth is, even if you could identify the exact moment or reason that things fell apart, it's probably not going to change the outcome. The relationship ended for a reason and clinging to what if. Really only prolongs your suffering. I remember this is what happened with that situation I was in, where I just was like trying to convince him constantly that if he committed, we would be really good together, that what if of like,
残酷的现实是，即使你能找出事情崩塌的确切时刻或原因，它也可能不会改变结局。关系结束是有原因的，执着于“如果”只会延长你的痛苦。我记得这就是我经历那段暧昧关系时发生的事情，我当时就是不断地试图说服他，只要他承诺，我们俩就会很合拍，那种“如果”就像是，
what if you just believed me for a second? What if you just saw what I saw? You know, then we could have this amazing life together that that whole situation was a fantasy. And I was trying to force somebody to believe in something that they didn't want proof of and that they didn't necessarily want. And what it was really about was control, me trying to control a situation that made me feel really vulnerable so that the outcome didn't make me feel worse about myself. Okay, so now that we understand the pain, hopefully a little bit better, I want to go through the life cycle of a breakup and what to expect. What are the signs that you're healing? What are the signs that you're getting better? What kind of awaits you in the next chapter
如果你哪怕相信我一秒钟会怎么样？如果你能看到我所看到的会怎么样？你知道的，那我们就能拥有这样一段美好的生活——而整个情况其实是一个幻想。我当时在强迫一个人去相信某种他们不需要证据、也不一定想要的东西。而这背后的真正原因其实是掌控欲，我试图掌控一个让我感到非常脆弱的局面，这样结果就不会让我对自己的感觉更糟糕。好了，既然我们现在对痛苦有了更好的理解，我希望梳理一下分手的生命周期以及会有什么期待。你正在康复的迹象有哪些？你正在变好的迹象有哪些？在这段心碎的下一个章节中，有什么在等待着你？
of this heartbreak? Heartbreak is obviously different for everyone, but the way the heart mends itself actually seems to follow a very similar pattern and set of timelines. Now, I can't give you an absolute number. I can't give you an exact date or the number of months that it's going to take before you feel better. But we can talk about the stages. There have been a couple of attempts to kind of do this to kind of categorize the life cycle of a breakup. The most famous one is obviously the stage of grief theory by Elizabeth Kulbler-Ross. This theory, you've probably heard of but it basically was developed to describe how people move through the grief that occurs when somebody dies. People then realize it also applies to the grief of when a relationship dies, but the stages
心碎对每个人来说显然都是不同的，但心灵自我修复的方式实际上似乎遵循着非常相似的模式和时间线。现在，我无法给你一个绝对的数字。我无法给你一个确切的日期或你需要多少个月才能感觉好点，但我们可以谈谈这些阶段。曾有过几次试图对分手的生命周期进行分类的尝试。最著名的显然是伊丽莎白·库伯勒-罗斯（Elizabeth Kubler-Ross）的悲伤五阶段理论。你可能听说过这个理论，它最初是为了描述人们在面对亲人离世时经历悲伤的过程。人们后来意识到，这也适用于关系消亡时的悲伤，但这些阶段是：
are denial, anger, bargaining, depression, and acceptance. The theory is you have to go through each stage in your own time to get to a point when you're really ready to move on. I find that that theory is quite accurate, but I also have my own model that I think describes it a little bit better and I describe it as the three waves of the breakup. So before you even get into the breakup, I think before you even actually start to be able to move on, you are going to go through that stage of shock and of denial. Every single one of us is going to have this. It could last a minute, a day, a month, three months. Essentially, it's going to maybe take a while for you to really realize the emotional situation you're in. And that's why it can take some time for your emotions to catch
否认、愤怒、讨价还价、抑郁和接受。该理论认为，你必须在自己的时间里经历每个阶段，才能达到真正准备好继续前进的时刻。我发现这个理论相当准确，但我也有自己的模型，我认为它能更好地描述这一过程，我将其描述为“分手的三个波涛”。所以在你甚至还没有真正进入分手阶段之前，在你可以开始释怀之前，我认为你将经历震惊和否认的阶段。我们每个人都会经历这一点。它可能持续一分钟、一天、一个月、三个月。本质上，你可能需要一段时间才能真正意识到你所处的情感境地。这就是为什么你的情绪可能需要一些时间才能赶上现实。就像我说的，我花了四个月的时间才真正为那次初恋分手感到悲伤，花了四个月我才哭出来，因为我当时还处于这种震惊的感觉中。
up to your reality. Like I said, it took me four months to really grieve that first breakup, four months before I even cried because I was still in this shock feeling. You know, you may wake up for a few days, you know, afterwards, just kind of forgetting that it even happened. You may really genuinely feel that you're fine. You're already over it. I'm sorry to say that feeling is a trick. That feeling is a lie. At some stage, the gates are actually going to open, and that's when the healing and the heartbreak really begins. And that's when the first wave actually occurs. The first wave of a breakup, of any breakup is what I call the emotional mess stage. After that shock falls away, this is when you first encounter, like, the true
你知道的，之后的几天里你可能会醒来，只是有点忘记了这件事的发生。你可能会真诚地觉得自己很好。你已经走出来了。我很遗憾地告诉你，那种感觉是个把戏。那种感觉是个谎言。在某个阶段，大门将会敞开，那才是疗愈和心碎真正开始的时候。而第一波涛也正是在那时发生的。分手的第一个波涛，任何分手的第一个波涛，就是我所说的“情感混乱阶段”。当那阵震惊消退后，这是你首次遭遇，真实地面对，
reality, the raw truth of the emotional wreckage of what's happened. In this first wave, you will do and you have permission to do stupid things. It's a given. You're going to get bangs. You're going to try desperately to be friends with your ex. You're going to keep going back looking for closure. You're going to get too drunk. You're going to cry in embarrassing places. It is a requirement. If you have not gone through this, you are probably still in the shock phase. What's really happening is that all the love that you have has nowhere to go. So you respond impulsively. You respond with great intensity. I tend to think of it as like the first stage of having an open wound. Like blood is just gushing everywhere. And that's totally normal. This is when I really recommend and I'm going to,
发生了什么的情感残骸的原始真相。在这第一波中，你将会做——而且你也被允许去做——蠢事。这是必然的。你会去剪个齐刘海。你会拼命地试图和你的前任做朋友。你会一遍又一遍地回去寻找释怀。你会喝得烂醉如泥。你会引人注目地在尴尬的地方哭泣。这是必经之路。如果你没有经历过这些，你可能还处于震惊阶段。真正发生的事情是，你拥有的所有的爱都无处可去。所以你的反应是冲动的。你的反应是极其强烈的。我倾向于认为这就像是开放性伤口的第一阶段。就像鲜血到处喷涌。这完全正常。正是在这个时候，我强烈建议——我知道这听起来很基础，
I know it's going to sound basic, but I really do recommend you go no contact for 30 days. Whatever terms you ended the relationship on, good or bad, neurologically, it's going to be easier for you to move on from this situation. If you are not constantly triggered, and reminded of their existence, or if their role and presence in your life is not continuing to be reinforced. You need to stop those neurons and stop those synaptic connections that associate you with them from firing. The way I really like to describe it is when you go no contact, you're able to hear your own voice and feel your own emotions more clearly. It's like being able to just have a conversation with yourself without hearing somebody else's voice like talking over
但我真的建议你断联30天。无论你们是以什么条件结束这段关系的，无论好坏，从神经学角度来看，从这种情况中走出来会更容易。如果你没有不断被触发，不断被提醒他们的存在，或者如果他们在你生活中的角色和存在没有继续得到强化。你需要停止那些神经元，停止将你与他们联系在一起的突触连接被激活。我真的很喜欢这样描述它：当你断联时，你能够更清晰地听到自己的声音，感受到自己的情绪。这就像能够只和自己对话，而没有别人的声音在对你
you. You're each going to handle this breakup very differently. And at some stage, like each of you is going to try and convince the other person to see it the way that you see it. You don't need that other voice talking over how you feel and interrupting your emotional processing. Going no contact just gives you the time to concentrate on what you think about the situation and to also just kind of work through the pain. I always say that like going cold turkey on a relationship might feel a lot more painful but it speeds the process up a lot compared to slowly trying to move away or slowly trying to withdraw from somebody, which is just going to make the pain and make the wound heal so much slower. During the first wave, typically an event will trigger you to move into
喋喋不休。你们俩对这次分手的处理方式会非常不同。在某个阶段，你们每个人都会试图说服对方以你的视角来看待问题。你不需要另一个声音来对你的感受指手画脚，打断你的情感处理过程。断联只会给你时间专注于你对这种情况的看法，同时也让你度过痛苦。我总是说，对一段关系采取“冷火鸡”（彻底戒断）式的处理方式可能会痛苦得多，但与慢慢试图疏离或慢慢试图从某人身边撤退相比，它大大加快了进程，而后者只会让痛苦和伤口愈合得慢得多。在第一波期间，通常某个事件会触发你进入
the second wave. And typically this is something that's a little bit unfortunate. You find out that they're seeing somebody new. You have a big confrontational chat after the no contact. You see their true colors. You realize finally the big reason you can't be together. This pushes you into the second wave where the real deep healing begins. Second wave, deep healing stage. The temporary fixes no longer work. Going out doesn't keep the pain away. You can't outrun the serious grief that this relationship isn't going to work. It's not going to come back. And this is when you feel very hopeless. You cry a lot. It feels very dark. It's also when you really have to look the pain in the eye. Surviving this wave is mainly about time. But there are some of the
第二波。通常这是一件有点不幸的事情。你发现他们有了新欢。在断联后，你们进行了一次激烈的对抗谈话。你看到了他们的真面目。你终于意识到你们不能在一起的重大原因。这把你推入了第二波，真正的深度疗愈由此开始。第二波，深度疗愈阶段。权宜之计不再奏效。外出无法让痛苦远离。你无法逃避这段关系无法维系、无法复合的严重悲伤。正是在这个时候，你会感到非常绝望。你会哭很多。感觉非常黑暗。这也是你必须直面痛苦的时候。熬过这波浪潮主要靠时间。但也有一些
things that will definitely help as well. So not dating is a big one. Being around your friends, really sinking deeper into your hobbies, dating yourself in a really active way, taking yourself out for dinner, filling up your social calendar with things that you're excited to do are all really going to help. When you start to kind of get into the flow of this, you're going to be thinking about them a lot less. You're going to be thinking like, hey, I think I'm going to survive this. That's when you experience the third wave, which is acceptance. But before you can get there, you are going to experience one more wave of grief.
事情绝对会有所帮助。所以，不约会是一个重要的方法。和你的朋友在一起，更深入地沉浸在你的爱好中，以一种非常积极的方式和自己约会，带自己出去吃晚餐，用你兴奋想做的事情填满你的社交日程，这些都会有所帮助。当你开始进入这种状态时，你会发现你想起他们的频率大大减少了。你会想，嘿，我想我能挺过去。就在那时，你经历了第三波，也就是接受。但在你到达那里之前，你将经历最后一波悲伤。
And I'm going to talk about why that is what it feels like and how to get through that infamous third wave after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also. an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers,
在这段短暂的广告之后，我将谈谈那种感觉是什么样的，以及如何度过那臭名昭著的第三波。2%。这是在也有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养韧性的方法。我将与作家、研究人员、
and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
以及其他健康与健身专家等对话，探讨那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。
Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam J.
让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed cracks. I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着去理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期节目，马克·拉蒙特·希尔大谈80年代的可卡因。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时准备谈论可卡因，但为了让大家知道我的意思。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了。我开始看出这里有一条贯穿线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上。
Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
谢谢你把那句话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at It。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们的主持人、你最喜欢的心理治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。
And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase
为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多杰出嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine），瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，在我们追求某事的过程中，我们太过于沉迷于追逐，
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid?
以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，却还在继续追逐，并且不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们都在盯着记分牌看。生活变成了关于赢和输。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns），达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在这个地球上做一个好人很重要？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself.
因为那是两个不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你只是真正地做一个好人。加入我，凯尔·盖恩斯，我们将在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标进行真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio App。搜索 Learn the Hardway 并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己
at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives
处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法院听证会揭示了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开始了长达数年的法庭之战以证明真相。你两次篡改了这特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探
to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. The West B and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税金被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。韦斯特·B和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的脑洞大开。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. There's two golden rules that any man should live by.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。
Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck.
规则一，千万不要惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也千万别惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在《The Girlfriends》的新一季中……天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。
I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在乎。所以她们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼，不。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。
On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I truly think the second hardest part of a breakup after, of course, like the initial devastation, is actually always going to be right before things get easier very quickly. And I know this from experience, not just my own, but from other people's. You know, the moment you think, I just don't think I can survive this any longer, doing everything I can. I can't stop thinking about them. That is truly when you come to a state of acceptance.
他会得到应有的惩罚。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。我真心认为，在经历了最初的毁灭性打击之后，分手的第二大难关，其实总是发生在事情很快变得轻松之前的那个时刻。我知道这一点，不仅凭我自己的经验，还有别人的经验。你知道的，当你认为“我真的觉得自己再也熬不下去了，我已经尽了全力，我无法停止想念他”的那一刻，那正是你真正达到接受状态的时候。
When you come to realize, like, the only way I can survive this is by understanding myself better and is by actually, going further into the belly of the beast. You begin to really find a lot more clarity. And this is where in this third wave, like I really recommend you start journaling about what you've learned. You begin to see patterns more clearly. You begin to be able to like really soak in the lessons. It may also be in this third wave when you contact them one last time. You do that final farewell. And it's when you really start to trust your intuition again about maybe seeing other people, making big life decisions.
当你开始意识到，嗯，挺过这一关的唯一方法就是更好地了解自己，真正深入了解问题的核心。你会开始真正发现更多的清晰感。这就是在第三波中，我强烈建议你开始写日记，记录你所学到的东西。你会更清楚地看到规律。你会开始能够真正吸收这些教训。也可能正是在这第三波中，你最后一次联系他们。你做了最后的告别。正是在这个时候，你开始重新相信自己的直觉，也许可以开始约会其他人，做出重大的人生决定。
What's the next chapter for you going to hold? You feel more optimistic for the first time in months than you feel pessimistic. I want to make something clear. It is totally normal to be in wave three or beyond, to be in like the total acceptance stage and still get flashbacks of them, to still find yourself thinking about them, even missing them. This is not a sign to get back. together. These involuntary memory flare-ups, they are no more than what we call mind pops. And I talked
人生的下一章会是什么样？几个月来，你第一次感到乐观的情绪多于悲观。我想澄清一件事。处于第三波或更往后、处于完全接受阶段，却依然会闪回关于他们的记忆，发现自己依然在想他们，甚至还在想念他们，这完全是正常的。这并不是复合的信号。这些不由自主的记忆爆发，不过是我们所说的心智闪现。我之前也谈过
about this in my book, actually, where I did my whole chapter on heartbreak. These mind pops are something that psychologists and scientists have labeled recently. It's basically where our brain just suddenly brings about memories and information to the surface so that we can determine whether it's still relevant or not. It is this involuntary memory recall that is triggered by the environment, triggered by something happening, by a smell, a song lyric, a place, a food. We don't even know it. And suddenly you're right back in that place and time reminiscing on them all those years later. If a memory is particularly emotionally loaded, like it's going to come up a few times. Maybe just because you're bored, maybe just because your inhibitions are down.
这个，实际上在我的书中，我专门有一章写心碎。这些心智闪现是心理学家和科学家最近给它们起的名字。这基本上是指我们的大脑突然将记忆和信息带到意识表面，以便我们判断它是否依然具有相关性。这种不由自主的记忆回溯是由环境触发的，由发生的某件事、某种气味、一首歌词、一个地方、一种食物触发的。我们甚至毫无察觉。突然之间，多年之后的你又回到了那个地方和那个时刻，回想起他们。如果一段记忆带有特别强烈的情感色彩，它就会出现好几次。也许只是因为你无聊，也许只是因为你的戒备心降低了。
don't try and be afraid, don't try and suppress these thoughts. They are super normal. They are nothing more than your brain just deciding to fire in strange ways. Do not let it make you think that you need to go back to this person. I want you to approach these mind pubs cautiously and with neutrality. It is totally normal that you're going to miss them. You felt connected. They were a part of your life.
不要试图害怕，不要试图压抑这些想法。它们超级正常。它们不过是你以奇怪方式运转的大脑做出的决定。不要让它让你觉得你需要回到这个人身边。我希望你以谨慎和中立的态度来对待这些心智闪现。你会想念他们，这完全正常。你们曾有过连接。他们是你生活的一部分。
maybe things ended in an unsatisfactory way. That doesn't mean that you still have to be emotionally invested in them. It's also essential to question how you may be romanticizing parts of your relationship that never actually happened. There's a reason why we only remember the good times. It's known as the Polyana principle. A positive cognitive bias is what is occurring, whereby we remember the good times more clearly than the bad, and therefore we fixate on them more
也许事情的结局并不令人满意。但这并不意味着你必须继续在情感上投入其中。质疑自己是如何将那些从未真正发生过的恋爱片段浪漫化的，这也是至关重要的。我们只记住美好时光是有原因的。这被称为波丽安娜效应。这是一种积极的认知偏差，表现为我们对美好时光的记忆比痛苦时光更清晰，因此我们更多地纠结于它们，
and they give us an unrealistic view of the relationship. Often we romanticise the past to protect ourselves from negative memories, and in the process, we engage in something called selective recall. When we think about our ex or some unrequited love, all we remember is what made them special. And all the other things, the unanswered messages, the lack of effort, the unanswered, happiness that is left out. And it's no wonder you can't move on when you are remembering your entire relationship incorrectly despite your best intentions. I'm going to say something you may not want to hear right now. But that's going to happen. There is no fast forwarding through a breakup.
并对这段关系产生不切实际的看法。通常，我们会将过去浪漫化，以此来保护自己免受负面记忆的伤害，在这个过程中，我们会进行一种叫做选择性回忆的行为。当我们想起前任或某些单相思时，我们记住的只有让他们变得特别的地方。而所有其他的事情——那些未回复的信息、缺乏的付出、那些未曾得到的幸福——都被遗忘了。难怪当你带着最好的意愿却记错了整段关系时，你无法走出来。我要说一些你现在可能不想听的话。但这是会发生的。失恋是没有快进键的。
I think grief, whether it lasts a week to five years, is the price you pay for love. And I think it's a pretty fair price. The second thing I'm going to say that you may not like is that you do have to find the beauty in this a little bit, or at least the romance. And what I mean romance, what I really mean is meaning. Why did this happen? How is this part of your story? What are you going to create from this? Because by gosh, you are going to build and make something beautiful of yourself and your life because of this pain not in spite of it. Like I genuinely, I said this at the beginning, breakups are just like such fertile soil to plant the seeds of your new life. There is so much you can do out of like out of the rubble of a breakup. Like I cannot express to you how my whole life is
我认为悲伤，无论是持续一周还是五年，都是你为爱付出的代价。而且我认为这是一个相当公平的代价。我要说的第二件事你可能也不会喜欢，那就是你确实需要从中找到一点美感，或者至少是浪漫。当我所说的浪漫，我真正意思其实是意义。为什么会发生这种事？这如何成为你故事的一部分？你将从这当中创造出什么？因为天哪，你将会因为这种痛苦——而不是尽管有这种痛苦——来建立和造就一个美丽的自己和你的人生。就像我发自内心地说过的，我在一开始就说过，失恋就像是肥沃的土壤，可以播下你新生活的种子。在失恋的废墟中，你可以做很多事情。我无法向别人表达，因为某人跟我分手，我的整个人生是如何
different because somebody broke up with me and my whole life is different in a way that is, and I can tell, is profoundly better. than what it would have been if I'd stayed, or if we'd broken up, you know, five months, six months later, or if we'd actually never been together. It all makes sense. It's all part of the story. So, I think it's time to give you some of my tips, the best tips that I use that I think are important for getting through this that are based in psychology. The first big tip that I have for you is to survive this breakup, you need to restructure your environment. This involves getting rid of any reminders of this person.
变得不同的，而且这种不同是我能看出来的，它比我如果继续留在那段关系里，或者比我们在五、六个月后分手，或者如果从一开始就没在一起，要好得多。这一切都说得通。这一切都是故事的一部分。所以，我想是时候分享我的一些建议了，这是我用过的、我认为基于心理学原理、对于度过难关非常重要的最好建议。给你的第一个重大建议是，要想熬过这场失恋，你需要重塑你的环境。这包括摆脱任何会让你想起这个人的人事物。
And then on top of that, introducing new objects, new colors, new things, new images that reflect the new life and new mindset that you are stepping into. After my first terrible breakup, I did a clean sweep. Everything that reminded me of him, they went in a box and it went into store. And I couldn't tell you where that box is now. I just needed it to be gone. I also ordered a bunch of posters of my favorite art to hang up on my walls. I also painted a bunch of stuff in my room. I moved all of my furniture around. I bought new bed sheets. I just wanted stuff that was going to represent me and represent, you know, this life that I wanted to have as a single person.
不仅如此，还要引入新的物品、新的颜色、新的事物、新的图像，它们反映了你正在迈入的新生活和新心态。在我经历第一次糟糕的分手后，我进行了一次彻底的大扫除。所有让我想起他的东西，都被装进一个箱子并收进了储藏室。现在我都不知道那个箱子在哪里了。我只是需要它消失。我还订购了一堆我最喜欢的艺术品海报挂在墙上。我还把房间里的很多东西重新刷了漆。我移动了所有的家具。我买新的床单。我只是想要一些能够代表我、代表我作为一个单身人士想要拥有的生活的东西。
Research in environmental psychology shows that our surroundings profoundly affect our emotions and behaviors, especially in times like this. There is this very famous equation that was described by this individual called Kurt Lewin. And his equation is basically that behavior, your behavior is a function both of the person you are and of your environment. So when your living space is filled with reminders of a past relationship, how do you expect yourself to behave any differently when you are continuously triggering memories and the emotional pain of this person and the fact they're not in your life anymore. You need to be so deliberate about changing your environment, rearranging furniture, redecorating, replacing so that the new physical cues in your environment
环境心理学研究表明，我们的周围环境会深刻影响我们的情绪和行为，尤其是在这样的时刻。有一个由库尔特·勒温（Kurt Lewin）这个人提出的非常著名的方程式。他的方程式基本上是：行为，你的行为是你是谁以及你的环境这两个函数的共同结果。所以，当你的生活空间里充满了过去关系的记忆时，当你不断触发记忆以及对这个人的情感痛苦、触发他们已经不在你生活中的事实时，你怎么能期望自己表现得有任何不同呢？你必须刻意去改变环境，重新摆放家具、重新装修、重新布置，好让环境中新的物理线索
symbolize the things that you care about, symbolize the things that are independently important to you and symbolize your new life. Okay, tip number two, get a project. and make it a project or a hobby or something that you have never showed interest in before and that they would know nothing about. For me, that was this podcast. I cannot tell you, like, how important this podcast was for me to get through those emotions. But what was so important about it was it was like I was learning all these new skills, I was creating this whole new life for myself that he didn't know anything about
象征着你在乎的事物，象征着对你个人而言重要的事情，并象征你的新生活。好的，第二个建议，找一个项目。把它作为一个你以前从未表现出兴趣、而对方对此一无所知的项目、爱好或其他事情。对我来说，那就是这个播客。我无法形容，这个播客对我度过那些情绪有多么重要。但它最重要的一点在于，就像我在学习所有这些新技能，我正在为自己创造一个他一无所知、
that had no, no connection to this individual. I also think that we are rarely as motivated to prove something to ourselves as we are when we are in deep emotional pain. You know, you really have like one of the purest forms of motivation for yourself right now. Heartbreak is like heroin for getting stuff done and for reinventing yourself. You know, whether that is throwing yourself into the gym, you know, writing a book, writing poetry, starting a garden, solo traveling, like there is a reason half of the music out there is breakup songs. Every feeling that you have is it's going to be right on the surface. It's so easy to access and it's so easy to take those feelings and to convert them into something that you are really, really proud of.
与这个人没有任何联系的全新生活。我也认为，当我们处于深深的情感痛苦中时，我们往往从未如此有动力去向自己证明某些事情。你知道，你现在确实拥有对自己最纯粹的动力之一。心碎就像是让人高效做事、重塑自我的海洛因。无论是投入到健身房中，写一本书，写诗，开始种园艺，独自旅行——正如俗话所说，外面的歌曲有一半都是失恋情歌，是有原因的。你的每一个感受都将展露无遗。它们非常容易触及，也很容易把这些情绪转化为让你感到非常、非常骄傲的事情。
Number three, my third tip is to get a breakup buddy. I was talking to my friend Grace about this the other day, but having a friend or a person that is going through it with you makes this whole process like totally more bearable. And I think it allows you to be more honest and reflective compared to with your friends who are maybe still in relationships or people who haven't been through a breakup in a while. When you talk through your breakup with your breakup buddy, you engage in a process that psychologist called co-regulation. And this is a This is where two people actually help regulate each other's emotions because they're going through something similar and they are sharing very vulnerably their story, their reflections,
第三，我的第三个建议是找一个失恋搭子。前几天我和朋友格蕾丝谈到这个，但有一个朋友或一个同样在经历这一切的人陪着你，会让整个过程变得完全可以忍受。而且我认为，与那些可能还在恋爱中的朋友，或者有一段时间没有经历过分手的人相比，这能让你更诚实、更有反思能力。当你和失恋搭子一起倾诉你的分手经历时，你就是在参与一个心理学家称之为“共调节”的过程。这是一个
and their truth. And it actually allows us to feed off other people's calm, to feed off the other person's emotions, to feed off their learnings. There was a 2011 study on emotional disclosure that found expressing painful emotions to someone who was in similar circumstances to you actually reduces depressive symptoms and it improves recovery time for all number of illnesses including heartbreak. It also just makes you a lot less lonely. I think the loneliness is the hardest part of this, right? Maybe since this relationship occurred of a lot of your friends have found themselves in relationships and maybe you're the last single person.
两个人实际上在帮助调节彼此情绪的过程，因为他们正在经历类似的事情，并且非常脆弱地分享他们的故事、反思以及他们的真相。这实际上让我们能够从别人的平静中汲取力量，从另一个人的情绪中汲取力量，从他们的学习中汲取力量。2011年的一项关于情感披露的研究发现，向处境与你相似的人表达痛苦的情感，实际上可以减少抑郁症状，并改善包括心碎在内的各种疾病的康复时间。它也让你没那么孤独。我认为孤独是最难的部分，对吧？也许自从这段恋情发生以来，你的很多朋友都找到了伴侣，而你可能是最后一个单身的人。
People are busy. Maybe you live in a new city. That loneliness can have you running back. to a less than good relationship faster than you can say boo because it is the only thing that's going to make you feel good. So find your person. Trust me when you start looking, they're everywhere. They're in book clubs, run clubs, raves, gallery opening, friends, birthday parties. You're going to find somebody who is also going through their biggest heartbreak just like you and it's going to be your biggest comfort. And I think it's going to be something you guys can always look back on, like you went through the trenches together. You went through this really hard time together. This kind of links to a bigger tip in general. You really need to get out of your head and into the
大家都很忙。也许你住在一个新城市。这种孤独感会让你比说“哎呀”还要快地奔回那段并不美好的关系，因为这是唯一能让你感觉良好的东西。所以，去找你的伴侣（搭子）吧。相信我，当你开始寻找时，他们无处不在。他们在读书俱乐部、跑步俱乐部、锐舞派对、画廊开幕式、朋友的生日派对上。你会找到一个也正在经历最大心碎的人，就像你一样，这将是你最大的慰藉。我想这也将成为你们以后可以回味的事情，你们曾一起共患难。你们一起度过了这段非常艰难的时期。这在某种程度上与一个更宏大的总体建议有关。你真的需要跳出自己的思维，走向
world and commit to meeting new people. You may have lost your main connection. You know, you may have lost this person that you love, but researchers estimate that that relationship is worth about five smaller friendships or connections. So what that means is that, you know, that's not a loss. Now you have all this space. It's like, finding a whole new closet that you get to fill. Like you have all this space in your life for new connections, new relationships, fill the closet. Fill the closet with these new people.
世界，并承诺去结识新的人。你可能失去了主要的伴侣。你知道，你可能失去了这个你爱的人，但研究人员估计，这段关系相当于大约五个较小的友谊或连接。所以这意味着，你知道，那并不是损失。现在你拥有了所有的空间。这就好比，发现了一个全新的衣柜，你可以去填满它。就像你的生活中有了所有这些空间来容纳新的连接、新的关系，去填满这个衣柜吧。用这些新的人填满这个衣柜。
That sounds really creepy. Just fill your time and your space with connections that platonically might outlast your next relationship or the one after that. My fourth tip is to use the power of visualization to allow yourself to see the relationship more clearly and also see your future more clearly. I want you to visualize the next five years of your life in two ways. The first way is what would your life look like five years from now if you'd stayed? You can write about this, you can journal this if you need, but what would it have looked like,
这听起来真的很诡异。只需用纯洁的友情连接来填满你的时间和空间，这些连接可能会比你的下一段感情或再下一段感情更持久。我的第四个建议是利用可视化的力量，让自己更清晰地看到这段关系，也更清晰地看到你的未来。我希望你以两种方式想象你未来五年的生活。第一种方式是，如果你留下来，五年后的生活会是什么样？你可以写下来，如果需要的话可以写日记，但如果真的留下来，
honestly, if you had stayed? And secondly, what do you actually want it to look like in five years? And what do you now have the opportunity to do because you are not in this relationship. This exercise just asks you to be really, really honest with yourself. There was a reason this relationship didn't work out. Even if the reason was simply because the other person wasn't in love anymore, there are things that can't be forced.
老实说，生活会是什么样？其次，你实际上希望五年后的生活是什么样？因为你没有身处这段关系中，你现在有机会去做什么？这个练习只是要求你对自己非常、非常诚实。这段关系没有结果是有原因的。即使原因仅仅是因为对方不再相爱了，有些事情也是无法勉强的。
And there are things that would have eventually eroded the relationship would have meant that you would have broken up further down the line. What was this relationship asking you to be? and what was it asking you to become that maybe wasn't going to be your best? And now that you're not in it, you now have this opportunity to shape the next five years, the next 10 years, 20 years of your life, in a whole different environment, a whole different space,
有些事情最终会侵蚀这段关系，这意味着你们在未来还是会分手。这段关系要求你成为什么样的人？它要求你变成的那个人，可能并不是最好的你？既然你已经不在其中了，你现在就有机会在完全不同的环境、完全不同的空间里，塑造未来五年、未来十年、二十年的生活，
maybe in all these different relationships and places, how are you going to go about it? I think what this question is really asking you to do is to just get clear on the vision for yourself. You know, it's just you. What do you want? what do you want to strive for? What do you want to turn this loss into?
也许在所有这些不同的关系和地方，你将如何着手去做？我认为这个问题真正要求你做的是，看清自己的人生愿景。你知道，这只是你。你想要什么？你想要为什么而奋斗？你想把这次损失变成什么？
Because there are like so many big wins that come out of just investigating and really questioning, what do I actually want from my life? And now you don't have somebody else in it that you have to think about. There's just so much more room for freedom. This really lends to my final tip after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also and escalator available.
因为仅仅通过调查和真正质疑“我到底从生活中想要什么”，就会带来很多巨大的胜利。现在你的生活中没有了另一个人需要你去考虑。有更多的空间来获得自由。在短暂的广告休息之后，这自然引出了我的最后一个建议。2%。这是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了我们这个奇怪现代世界中精神坚韧、健身和建立韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看穿主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起发炎。我们搞错了。我们在世界上恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J.
让自己经历一些苦难，你在另一端就会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方的“TWO percent”。你还记得黛安·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA上拍打小肯（Little Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed cracks. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
我是亚历克斯·英格利斯（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的访谈，畅谈80年代的快克可卡因。坦白说，84年对我很重要，不只是因为快克。我随时都可以在某天谈论快克，只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，在这一点上，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始看到有一条贯穿线。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在桌面上。
Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
谢谢你把那句话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。
And in recognition of mental health awareness, this month. I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you have. here on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different
为了表彰本月的心理健康意识，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，在我们追求某事物的过程中，我们太过于沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这个事物。而我们还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要吗？你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的
intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free our heart radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct?
动机，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正做一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就治愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的IHeart Radio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。在2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德（Clayton Echard）发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场历时多年的法庭之战来证明真相。你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试，艾伦女士，对吗？
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税钱被用在什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·莱斯皮安（Greg Alespian）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我惊呆了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这还没完。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。
Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck.
规则一，永远不要招惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要招惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在《女朋友们》的新一季中……天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。
I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。于是她们决定自己动手。我说，噢，见鬼，不。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝。
On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. I think we often look for closure in the other person. and we look for closure in that final conversation, that final thing they're going to say to us, it's going to make us realize why it ended, why it was the way it was, my final tip.
在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方。我想我们经常在另一个人身上寻找解脱。我们在那最后一次对话中、在那最后一件他们要对我们说的事情中寻找解脱，那会让我们意识到为什么会结束，为什么会是这样，我的最后一个建议。
I need you to write the story of your relationship and write the finish or the closing chapter of your relationship for yourself, as if you are telling the story of your relationship as a folk story or as a lesson to a younger, a younger version of you or to your future children or almost like a fairy tale. Write the beginning, right at the middle of the relationship, and right at the end, but also write why you think it ought to happen.
我需要你为自己写下你的恋爱故事，写下你的关系的结局或收尾章节，就好像你把你的恋爱故事当作一个民间故事，或者当作给一个更年轻的你、给未来的孩子的教训，或者几乎像一个童话故事一样讲出来。写下开始，写下关系的中间部分，写下结局，但也要写下你认为它为什么会发生。
And maybe even if you want to project into the future, write about why this relationship was actually a stepping stone and what it may be guiding you to that is bigger than you. This really leverages the power of something we call narrative psychology. Narrative psychology is basically the study of how we make sense of our lives through stories. And it plays a really powerful role in healing after a breakup. According to the narrative psychologist Dan P. McAdams, we construct our identity through personal narratives that link our past, present, and imagine future into a coherent whole.
甚至如果你想投射到未来，写下这段关系实际上是如何成为一块垫脚石的，以及它可能在引导你走向比你更伟大的事物。这真正利用了一种我们称之为叙事心理学的东西的力量。叙事心理学基本上是研究我们如何通过故事来理解我们的生活。它在失恋后的治愈中起着非常强大的作用。根据叙事心理学家丹·P·麦克亚当斯（Dan P. McAdams）的说法，我们通过将过去、现在和想象的未来连结成一个连贯整体的个人叙事来构建我们的身份。
And when something disrupts that story and doesn't make sense, sense with what we thought was going to happen like a breakup, that's when we experience a lot of pain. The story is disrupted, like the plot line that we once shared is suddenly incomplete. So, writing the story of your relationship as a lesson or from your perspective, allows you to engage in that reconstruction process. And it allows you to really make meaning from this grief and from this loss in a manner that is very, very powerful. I want to give you, a bonus tip, speaking of closure and healing, and I know I've talked about this in another episode on Heartbreak, but I'm going to say it again, I need you to make a breakup playlist.
而当有什么东西扰乱了这个故事，并且与我们原本以为会发生的事情（比如分手）不相符时，这就是我们经历大量痛苦的时候。故事被打乱了，就像我们曾经共享的情节突然不完整了。因此，把你的恋爱故事当作一个教训或从你的角度写下来，可以让你参与到那个重构过程中。它能让你以一种非常、非常强大的方式，真正从这种悲伤和失落中汲取意义。我想给你一个额外的建议，说到解脱和治愈，我知道我在关于心碎的另一集里谈过这个，但我还是要再说一遍，我需要你制作一个失恋播放列表。
Maybe you already have one, but music and heartbreak are like the perfect pairing. A 2014 study actually found that breakup songs help you heal because they promote emotional expression and therefore give you an outlet compared to emotional suppression. There's also this additional funny part to this tip as well, which is that I think having a very specific breakup playlist actually allows you to track how your response or how your healing is going based on how you respond to the music. So what I mean by that is that it's often very hard to see how far you've come, how much your grief is actually moving or healing because we don't always have that linear like linear state of mind when we're going through something really,
也许你已经有了一个，但音乐和心碎简直是绝配。2014年的一项研究实际上发现，失恋歌曲可以帮助你治愈，因为它们促进了情感表达，因此与情感压抑相比，为你提供了一个宣泄口。这个建议还有一个额外有趣的部分，那就是我认为拥有一个非常具体的失恋播放列表，实际上可以让你根据你对音乐的反应来追踪你的反应或你的治愈进展。所以我的意思是，通常很难看出你已经走了多远，你的悲伤实际上在多大程度上在移动或治愈，因为当我们经历非常、
really difficult. Recently I listened back to my breakup playlist from that year of breakups. And I remember listening to these songs and sobbing and I remember having such an emotional reaction. And I listened to those songs the other day and I felt nothing. I just felt, I just felt neutral. I didn't feel sad. I didn't feel nostalgic. I didn't feel excited. I just felt nothing. And it was this really profound way of seeing how I have changed and how I've obviously, I've very obviously healed, but how like something that I once thought was going to define my life and then I was never going to recover from. I did. Something I thought I was never going to get over. I got over and my life is now so, so much better. And I think that's really where I want to kind of finish this episode.
非常困难的事情时，我们并不总是有那种线性的思维状态。最近我回听了我那年失恋的失恋播放列表。我记得听着这些歌泣不成声，我记得有过如此情绪化的反应。而前几天我又听了那些歌，我什么也没感觉到。我只是觉得，我只是觉得中立。我没有感到悲伤。我没有感到怀旧。我没有感到兴奋。我什么也没感觉到。这是一种非常深刻的方式，让我看到自己是如何改变的，以及我很明显地已经治愈了，而且曾经我认为会定义我的人生、我永远无法恢复的事情，我做到了。我认为我永远无法走出的阴影，我走出来了，我的生活现在好得多、好得多了。我想这真的是我想结束这一集的地方。
Like, it's very easy to feel pessimistic about love. And it's very easy to feel pessimistic about love. and it's very easy to feel like because this relationship didn't work out, I'm never going to find anyone better. Because I'm feeling so intense and deeply pained by the ending of this relationship, that's a sign that this person was the one. That's just not the case. I never thought I would feel pain, any deeper pain than the way I did with my first boyfriend. And then I did. I felt even more pain for somebody who was a lot less deserving of my love.
就像，对爱情感到悲观是很容易的。对爱情感到悲观是很容易的，而且很容易觉得因为这段感情没有结果，我再也找不到更好的人了。因为我对这段感情的结束感到如此强烈和深切的痛苦，这说明这个人就是真命天子。事实并非如此。我从没想过我会感受到比跟我的第一任男友在一起时更深切的痛苦。然后我确实感受到了。对于一个更不配得到我的爱的人，我感受到了更痛苦的滋味。
And even then, like, that actually said nothing more than that I was just attached. And it was always going to be hard to get over. And now I'm in this amazing relationship. And I wish that I could just sit down with my younger self and just say, you've just got to, you've just got to get through this. This is an important emotional experience. And you're going to find love. if not in your 20s, if not in your 30s, eventually you will. I always love hearing stories of people who find love a little bit later on. I think about, you know, my aunt who dated terrible men for years and then at 57 met like the love of her life, who she's never been more in love with and who she just adores.
即便如此，这也只能说明我只是产生了依恋。而要克服它总是很困难的。现在我处于一段美妙的恋情中。我真希望我能和年轻时的自己坐下来，对她说，你只需要，你只需要挺过这一关。这是一次重要的情感体验。你会找到爱的，即使不是在你的20多岁，不是在你的30多岁，最终你都会找到的。我总是喜欢听那些稍微晚一点找到真爱的人的故事。我想到了，你知道的，我的姑姑，她跟糟糕的男人约好了多年，然后在57岁时遇到了她一生的挚爱，她从未如此深爱过一个人，而且她简直崇拜他。
Or my grandma, who, you know, divorced my grandfather in her 40s and then met who I really do considered to be my grandfather and he like moved her to Australia and took it to Africa and made her an important part of his business and just think she's incredible at 90 years old. True love really does exist and sometimes I do think it's waiting behind heartbreak. It's begging you to let go, to leave this person, to learn as much as you can from this situation because it knows what else is coming and I know you're in so much pain right now. I know you think you're never going to get over them but whenever you feel pessimistic about the future without the minute, look for the big love stories because you will find them. And remember, like, your biggest love story, like you are the love of
或者我的奶奶，你知道的，在40多岁时与我爷爷离婚，然后遇到了我真正认为的爷爷的那个人，他把她带到澳大利亚，带去了非洲，让她成为他生意中的重要一part，并且认为她在90岁时依然不可思议。真爱确实存在，有时我确实认为它正在心碎的背后等待着。它在恳求你放手，离开这个人，从这种情况中尽可能多地学习，因为它知道接下来会发生什么，我知道你现在痛苦不堪。我知道你以为你永远无法忘记他们，但每当你对没有那个人的未来感到悲观时，去寻找那些伟大的爱情故事，因为你会找到它们的。记住，就像，你最大的爱情故事，就像你是你自己生命的挚爱。
your own life. The relationship you have with yourself matters more than anything. And it's from that that all other relationships form. So focus on you for a while, focus on being so magnetic and amazing and in love with yourself that whoever comes to the door next, whoever you meet next, whether it's in two months, two years or 10 years is just going to undeniably know that you know yourself, know that you deserve respect and know their feelings for you are true and that you're the one and that they love you. And I'm sure absolutely positively, like you can take me to the bank that you will find somebody like that, even if you are in the pits of sadness and despair right now. So thank you so much for listening to this episode. I hope that this guide has been helpful.
你与自己的关系比什么都重要。所有其他关系都是由此形成的。所以有一段时间专注于你自己，专注于变得如此富有磁性、如此了不起、如此深爱自己，以至于无论下一个敲门的人是谁，无论你接下来遇到谁，无论是在两个月、两年还是十年后，都会无可否认地知道你了解自己，知道你值得尊重，知道他们对你的感情是真实的，知道你就是那个人，而且他们爱你。我敢百分之百确信，你可以打包票，你会找到这样的人，即使你现在正处于悲伤和绝望的深渊中。非常感谢你收听这一集。希望这份指南对你有所帮助。
there was so much more I wanted to say. I had to deliberately like just not talk about so much other stuff. I really wanted to talk about like when you know, when you know it's time to date again, what to do if somebody moves on first. But I feel like we might just have to do a part two of this episode because I spoke for way too long. But yeah, I'm sending you a lot of love with your little heartbroken at the moment. I'm sure you're taking very good care of it. But I hope that you're healing and I hope that you're mending and I hope that this episode you can take something from it and put it into practice. If you have made it this far, leave a few emojis down below that explain such capture where you are in the breakup right now. And whether you're in wave one, wave two or
还有很多我想说的话。我不得不刻意不去谈论很多其他的事情。我真的很想谈谈诸如什么时候你知道是时候再次约会了，如果有人先move on了该怎么办。但我觉得我们可能不得不做这一集的第二部分，因为我讲得太久了。但是，是的，向此刻心碎的你发送许多爱。我相信你把它照顾得很好。但我希望你在治愈，我希望你在复原，我希望你可以从这一集中吸收一些东西并付诸实践。如果你坚持听到了这里，请在下方留下一些表情符号，来解释或捕捉你目前在分手中的阶段。无论你是在第一波、第二波还是
wave three. I want to know I'm setting love to my wave one, my wave one people. I'm sure it's very, very brutal. But yeah, leave a little comment down below. The emojis that describe your current state of mind with your breakup, but also what wave you're in. Make sure to maybe share this with somebody else who you think might really need to hear it, your breakup buddy. And follow us as well on Instagram at that psychology podcast. If you want to share how you're going, share how this episode helped you, any suggestions, or if you want a part two to this episode as well, I always love to hear from you guys and make sure that you are following wherever you are listening, whether that is on Apple, on the IHat radio app, on Spotify, so that you know when we post.
第三波。我想知道，我向我的第一波人发送爱，我的第一波人们。我确信这是非常、非常残酷的。但是，是的，在下方留下一个小评论吧。用表情符号描述你目前与分手的心态，以及你处于哪一波。确保把这个分享给其他你认为真正需要听到它的人，你的失恋搭子。并在Instagram上关注我们@thatpsychologypodcast。如果你想分享你的近况，分享这一集如何帮助了你，有任何建议，或者如果你也想要这一集的第二部分，我总是喜欢听你们大家的意见，并确保无论你在哪里收听，无论是在Apple、IHat radio应用程序上还是在Spotify上，都要关注，这样你就会知道我们什么时候发布
new episodes. But with all that in mind, thank you again for listening. And until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself, and we will talk very, very soon. On the Look Back at it podcast, 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it, with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
新节目。但考虑到所有这些，再次感谢您的收听。直到下一次，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点，我们很快就会再聊。《Look Back at It》播客，1979年，对我来说那是一个大时刻。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利斯。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时期的，与我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈80年代。那是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit are honest? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to.
在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，你们好吗？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你最喜欢的治疗师和主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在其他地方真的不安全，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人承担起责任是诚实的？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。
Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Lesbian.
在AHA广播应用程序、Apple Podcast或您获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《Learn the Hard Way》。在2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试，艾伦女士，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·莱斯皮安。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%.
迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
那是当有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了我们这个奇怪现代世界中精神坚韧、健身和建立韧性的科学。让自己经历一些苦难，你在另一端就会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方的“TWA%”。
When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, They take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己动手。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝。
On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方。这是一个IHeart播客。保证是由人类制作的。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。